- [Kelly] You look so nice.
I love this outfit!
- I appreciate it.
- [Kelly] Is it green?
- Yes. Yes.
- [Kelly] I dunno what that is.
I love it.
- It's greenish.
- Greenish. Okay.
Am I color-blind? Is it not green?
- I mean...
(Kelly laughs)
- Greenish.
- What's that?
- Well, I have to tell you, see?
Well, I come bearing a gift.
- [Kelly] You're my favorite guest.
- Yes. Here's the thing.
My wife, Jazmyn Simon,
wrote a children's book.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
- It's called "The Most Perfect You".
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It's an ode to motherhood and self-love.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And it's a reminder to anyone
who's ever compared themself to anyone,
that they're perfect exactly
the way that they are.
(audience applauds)
- I hope the book's in there for my kid.
- [Dule] See, in honor of Rad Moms Week,
one rad mom, my wife, Jazmyn Simon,
wanted to present to you, another rad mom,
this token of love to remind you
that you are and always will be
the most perfect you.
- I love this!
We read every night.
- [Dule] It's a great book.
- Literally, my kids, we read every night,
and my daughter loves it.
And she loves the ones
where she feels represented.
Like it's a girl, it's about
a girl, she loves that.
- It's a beautiful story.
So I really hope they enjoy it.
- This is awesome.
What a cool thing to do.
So how old are your kids?
- Well, we have a 17-year-old.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh,
you gotta stretch.
- Named Kennedy Irie,
who is off to Northwestern next year.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah? Congratulations.
- [Dule] So very proud of her.
And we have a two-year-old named Levi,
who is running the show.
He runs the show.
- Oh my gosh. Levi. Those cheeks?
- He's such such a joy.
- Oh my gosh.
I know the baby smell, all of it.
I had a puppy on me earlier
and I'm still smelling it.
- [Dule] Oh, man.
- Do y'all have animals?
- He actually wanted to come today.
I said, "Dada's gonna do an interview."
"I wanna come do an interview."
- [Kelly] I love that.
- But Mama, you can come, too.
- Bring them! Next time.
It's a family event,
I'm just saying.
So wait, we were just talking
about first ladies, though.
And I know everybody knows
you were on "West Wing", right?
So did you ever,
you had to have at some point,
just like taken a tour, at
least, of the West Wing.
And if you didn't, what a travesty.
- [Dule] I did.
I got a chance to go there a few times.
First, I was able to go there
during the Clinton administration
a couple times.
And I was able to go there
during the Obama administration
and during the Bush administration.
- Wow.
- Yeah, it was, I know the place.
- You were checking all those boxes.
- [Dule] I know the place pretty well.
- Yeah.
- [Dule] Pretty well.
- Okay.
So what was the coolest thing
you ever got to do there?
- [Dule] Well, I will say
the coolest coolest thing
that I ever got a chance to do
was to bring my grandmother
to the Oval Office.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- That was pretty surreal
because my family's from Jamaica.
So she emigrated and then to see
her grandchild now be able to
bring her to the Oval Office.
- [Kelly] That's is pretty cool.
- She said, "Look what I lived to see.
Look what I lived to see."
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
(audience cheers)
That's powerful.
- [Dule] The second coolest thing
that I got a chance to do
was to tap dance on the
roof of the White House.
- [Kelly] What?!
- [Dule] Yeah.
I got a chance.
- [Kelly] How did you swing that?
- [Dule] Well, one, I'm a tap dancer.
- [Kelly] Well, no, I know that part,
you're a dancer.
But they just let people up on the roof?
They never let me, and I've
been there several times.
- I was giving a tour around the place
and I ended up being in this room,
and it was between the
residence and the West Wing.
Or the residence and the East Wing,
there's like a portico.
There's a window going out there.
And I said,
"Is it okay if I just
go out there and dance?
I mean, if I can,"
and they said, "Sure."
I went out there and I tap-danced
and there you go.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Then on top of that,
I was able to dance out in
the Press Briefing Room.
- [Kelly] I love it, you're like,
"I'm gonna dance all over."
- [Dule] Oh, yeah. I'm gonna dance over.
In that shot, I also paid
homage to Gregory Hines,
'cause there's a step in there that I did
that is always Gregory Hines' step
and I gotta do it here.
- Okay. What's the one move?
I don't know.
- I'll show you.
- Oh, you did the turn!
Okay.
- You see what I'm saying?
(audience cheers)
- I love Gregory.
I always gotta big up Gregory
every time I have a chance to do it.
You know what I mean?
- I love that.
I just love that you love dancing so much.
It feels so good.
- Right.
- So wait, you're now doing
the remake of "The Wonder Years".
- [Dule] Yes.
- So did you, were you
a fan of the original?
- [Dule] I was a fan of the original.
I really enjoyed it.
You couldn't be a child of the '80s
and not be a fan of the original show.
Who didn't have a crush on Winnie Cooper?
- [Kelly] I never
stopped hearing her name.
- But I did also realize at that time
that I did not see myself
reflected in the show.
As much as I love this show
and appreciate this show,
I didn't see myself.
Even as we were talking
about with the book,
representation matters.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
It's empowering.
So when the opportunity came up for me
to do this show,
I wanted to jump at it.
I knew that Saladin Patterson
was the creator of the show,
who I'd known for years.
He's a dynamic writer.
And then when I knew that EJ Williams
was gonna be a part of it,
and Saycon Sengbloh and Laura Kariuki,
I just thought it was important
to be able to expand the lens.
"The Wonder Years" belongs to all of us.
"The Wonder Years" is not just
from one group of people.
This is one story of "The Wonder Years".
I think the show can be re-imagined
in many different ways.
- Absolutely.
- [Dule] You know, America
is a great melting pot,
and I think if we can show that more,
it can also help bridge gaps
and unify people and
bring people together,
and that's one reason I
want to be part of that.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] 100%.